thank you
[Music]
so in a fit of irony
and ubereats driver
was killed and eaten by the person that
they were delivering food to that's
[__] up dude
so maybe they ordered the wrong meal
because they're like I want a human but
you came over with McDonald's maybe
their name was Uber and so Uber Eats oh
wow you eat the Uber you're both wrong
so this guy named Oscar Solis he's 30
years old he was arrested faces a first
degree murder charge the Sheriff's
Office says that he was recently
released from prison in Indiana shout
out let's go Colts let's go baby let's
go this year's difference Anthony
Richardson let's go cannibalism let's go
Colts well it's about time Indiana got
their own thank you you never talk about
it yeah he has a link It's Always
Somewhere Else the cat has lengthy
criminal history including bursaries he
was also not registered as a felon in
Florida violating his parole and um they
say this is a horrific Crime of Passion
the person you know
um is it a common passion you always say
the word evil right the person this
person is evil this was demonic this
individual is what he did was demonic
says Sheriff Chris noko
um he says the driver was making his
last delivery Wednesday April 19th when
he texts his wife he would be wrapping
up and getting home soon oh all it
appears is that there was a gentleman
who was working during his last delivery
for the night and this person killed him
for no reason and took him away from his
family
the sheriff said his wife texted her
husband several times did not get a
response after several hours reported
him missing that night deputies searched
Thursday for the missing Uber Eats
driver and ubereats provided law
enforcement with information on his last
whereabouts using GPS
they showed that he was last at a home
along
a strange place called The Moog Road in
Holiday Florida sounds like cannibals to
me according to the sheriff they say
they responded to the home and searched
the area where the GPS was reporting
that he was at they couldn't find
anything the following day law
enforcement returns to the area
they spoke with the roommate of this guy
Solas Who provided video at the home and
you can actually see the victim walking
up to the house to deliver food the
video gets cut off and then you see on
the following day the suspect was
carrying trash bags with another
individual and you see them carrying
these trash bags around the side of the
house I think they had a buffet together
he found other like
cannibal homies
on like cannibal.com you definitely
can't cut up a body without with a
roommate yeah that's not like in on it
right the smells imagine the smells dude
exactly how do you find other like like
like-minded Souls like is it like
seeking arrangements or something are
you friends in bubble match
so investigators say that the the solace
pulled the victim into the home tried to
Rob him and then his ring and car keys
were later found inside the sheriff's
office is looking for two individuals
who also left the home about an hour
before the victim's death
um but yeah they they believe that this
was an incident
where the guy was killed in this member
oh God
specifically cannibalism was mentioned
no I kind of just like like did that
just for funds
because it's because the Uber Eats
driver and I was like oh they also ate
them you know what you know okay so they
so he do you know why he got killed then
did it for fun because cannibalism makes
sense it's like sick [__]
so why would he just kill him then
here's the thing I don't know that they
didn't eat it I don't think they haven't
we don't know that we don't know we
don't know there's no motive no they
didn't say they're just saying like he
was arrested they dismembered the guy
and it was just because they see the
bags yeah yeah it could have been like
random killing robbery went wrong
because I was like oh they probably just
wanted to kill him for his money or
something went South yeah or he
witnessed them doing some cannibal [__]
oh [__] no and they're like well we got
to kill this guy too now right
right cannibalism just keeps making its
way back in does it I just thought it's
like okay he's an Uber Eats guy he's
bringing delivery but then like he's for
dinner and I was like that kind of
worked for me so me and my buddy was
looking at um we were looking at
um businesses that are super high margin
that's very low competition but it does
extremely well and it's very stable and
guess what showed up crime scene cleanup
companies really yeah and there's
actually one that's like on social media
and there's like it's they post a grossy
[__] right like you like the the the the
police will call you and so you could
have these stable government contracts
also like they'll be the go-to if they
show up to a house because the
neighbor's like something snake and then
they're like what is it and it's like a
hoarder that died and it's like oh my
God and then the cops are gonna [__]
investigate and clean it it's a it's an
open shut case right so then they call
your company and then you come in
and you just have to clean everything up
and then they sell the house but the
jobs start at like 7K dude oh a month
let's start a business right you guys
down let's start a business
style that's at the price of your whole
mentality uh I need a reservation for
12. that's how many bodies it is it's
like hey we got some splatter brains
again you know and then it's like oh
it's [__] I hate fresh splatter
brains dude I can't believe I complained
about coming to JK sometimes right some
of the [__] that people gotta do we have
no windows in here there's no sun they
get paid good but it's a dirty job you
know like wobble Grill again yeah dirty
jobs but not trained they do shitty
things to the chicken in there
I think is the male to female ratio of
people that work that job
specific
good cleanup companies women
guarantee you it's it's it's immigrants
and convicts workers oh hey that's good
for them dude that's kind of a good gig
yeah
it's definitely hard work that
definitely sucks yeah but it made me
think about this because it's like yeah
it's cannibal clean up all that like I'm
like you know what I I always thought
the police department had a thing and
then the cops did it but I was like oh
no way after the crime scene like
they're not gonna [__] clean and
scrub and do all this [__] the forensics
or the detectives get to label
everything right so the cleanup crew
doesn't touch it yeah well when they're
done with everything like it's not the
forensics guys to like [__] fold
everything and do the laundry and you
know like provide you with fresh Linens
yeah it's like yeah this guy was
murdered on the bed but then they just
[__] took pictures and they're like
oh all right someone else do this yeah
and then the homeowners like
oh you know and then so they yeah
so when my hero Robert Mueller was
investigating Donald Trump
he never said that Donald Trump
didn't collude with Russia he said that
he couldn't prove that he was innocent
and that's all that I'm saying here I
don't know that they didn't eat the guy
you don't know that it just doesn't say
anything about that at all oh my God it
doesn't say [__] about it it does have
the hints of like when an unplanned
killing
you know you know about those yeah like
when it's like a really messy uh Cleanup
in terms of like oops we killed we
didn't mean to usually it ends with them
like chopping something up oh you know
what in a penny all right this is
exactly what happened the guy that
helped take out the trash bags after
eating another guy no no no there was no
cabinet all right so so the two guys
were cheating on their wives with each
other and it's a very very Christian
Community and it's a gay is No-No yeah
okay so and then they were like a lot of
details here they're like hey honey you
wanna [__] it you hungry like they just
okay babe they just [__] so hard
KFC and they're like I'll get Uber so
then Uber guy brings over the bucket of
chicken they get horny again and they're
just [__] l70. sucking each other off
so hard
and then he's all like ringing the
doorbell texting nothing drumstick suck
it drunk okay no no but they didn't get
the drumstick yet so the Uber guys like
he's blowing up their phone Uber
delivery yeah
the guy's holding him like this he has
the guy sucking and he's licking his
dick and he's [__] spinning right and
then spinning yeah
is just standing up it's called love
making right and and then and then the
Uber guys like hello and then he goes to
the back hello and then he sees them he
goes oh no and then the guy looks oh
[__]
yeah oh no it didn't it's a small
neighborhood
you know the guy it is a clear door yeah
so here's the thing they have to kill
him now break for the [__] wood door
they have to kill him now because I'm
gonna tell everybody all the Christians
the pastor of the church
no no the guy that was sucking off was a
pastor the pastor was a sucker offer guy
and in the Uber Eats guy was like
oh here's the chicken he goes no no no
wait wait wait and then they kill him
with what
with the dicks yeah with 2000 PSI come
on
because they're like the secret the
secrets gotta be like wanted bullets but
come yeah yeah it's over it's like
Cersei and and and [__] Jamie pushing
bran you know you push him down the
stairs they cut them up and eat them
yeah and honestly yeah
if bran had died the show would have
been 10 times better it would have been
he's [__] annoying huh slow talking
ass [__] hopefully they redo the show
hey check out my website brandsex.com
[__] ass week [__] not into
it I hate him not the real King to me
you think that was the first ever
invention of a wheelchair bran probably
it's the first wheelchair first
prototype you know they yeah so they eat
them
look all I know is that's why we have
wheelchair ramps everywhere even though
it makes no sense all we know is that
they ordered chicken and got horny again
and they were just like oh oh oh I can't
resist you I love you so much goes I
should have been gay from the beginning
you know let's leave our wives you know
and then he's like I should be the gay
as a baby he's like Uber Eats Uber Eats
and then they're like oh I can't believe
it Pastor Jones you know exactly
so I'm glad we did the like a crime
scene reconfiguration yeah CSI JK Yeah
we actually see we sold it we're pretty
good at this motive there's motive
there's romance there's bro there's
character did you do a live action dude
dude
oh
foreign